[Music]
failed presidential campaign but she
just went on conservative radio to open
up about what happened and took some new
shots at president Trump I don't have
any personal stake in this presidency I
have a citizen state I am as you might
guess very much worried by the actions
and rhetoric of current president I've
been very disappointed in the way that
he has conducted himself she went on to
suggest if you Hewitt that racism in
America has become more politically
acceptable in the trump era I think
there has proven to be more white
supremacists and white nationalists than
I wish there were in our country as we
saw tragically in Charlottesville and
other places and they have made common
cause with the president's agenda out of
their own mouth that he is someone that
they are counting on to promote it all
right Greg it's your lucky day we start
another show with Hillary Clinton I
can't get enough of her also I love the
conservative radio you used to go after
liberals not anymore
well they don't go on they don't get is
out state but you its identity driven
politics but that were that were created
help create by her cynical campaign that
led to a lot of this divisive nough
swimming and what's called the big pool
fallacy Trump will have some creepy fans
because when you have a lot of fans some
of them are bound to be creepy the
bigger the pool the more likely there
might be a creep in that pool however
you have to be cognizant if you're the
lifeguard should you say something and I
think one of the one of the flaws with
Donald Trump it's a salesman's flaw you
never want to turn down a sale it's not
it's actually not a more it's not a
moral choice it's not a correct choice
but it's a part of thinking that like
the money the money is green so you
never turn down a sale you never know
you never know
damn anyone until somebody else comes
along so there's a there's a glimmer of
truth here but the other issue here is
that the Democrats have a problem you
remember how they made Al Gore the
president of global warming because they
couldn't make him president so they gave
him something to keep a business a game
a cause so he couldn't hurt anybody they
got to make her president of something
like my angry book club so that she goes
off and does some stuff or she could be
Bill Clinton's own defense attorney when
those cases come up she could actually
interrogate juanita Broadway how good
would that be if they hadn't had to
close the Clinton Global Initiative she
could be doing that but as far as that's
not available to her did you try to get
Hillary Clinton on your radio show no
not that I know well I didn't think she
was gonna come on I know we're asking on
Fox & Friends and a regular basis it
never happened she had no interest when
she was trying to be present United
States of coming on it's the biggest
mistake that both Al Gore John Kerry who
came on as Secretary of State and
Hillary Clinton did make because if you
come on and as Juan as you know if you
want to use some of your best segments
we're on with people and in this show in
particular would disagree with you
because you win people over and some of
you don't but at least you go in there
I'm gonna bleed gonna get your hands
dirty and she's in this interview said
uranium one that's still going on and
still everyone prove this didn't exist
well there's a problem with that that
story's moving and he goes son problem
with my emails they made it the number
one story it shouldn't have been well
the problem is there was a lot there but
you didn't go in and and attack it you
know what she did and admitted it in
this interview I didn't even listen nor
did her staff how do you know how to
fight an uphill battle went over
independence if you don't know the other
side's even doing well I think this this
is a real short coming for Democrats I
mean you know imagine the kind of flack
I get being on fox but they don't yeah
but that's true too but they don't have
a sense of the ability to come here and
use this as a forum to influence people
so I think that's why it's great that
she went on hugh hewitt's show and i
think that it's very important that you
have sufficient respect for people even
if you disagree with them to talk with
them but also because people do i would
love to have her on the daily briefing
in case you're watching hillary but if
you come on a place where you aren't
necessarily going to be guaranteed a
warm reception
and you're pleasant and you try to make
a couple of good points that you the the
viewer will say well that was good like
that was nice and she was kind she was
fine whatever and unless it's a total
train wreck no and I mean you know
appreciate the upside there if you
believe in yourself and you're confident
and what you have to offer that you're a
great candidate that you have ideas that
are compelling that would resonate with
the American people now why wouldn't you
take a chance and get in the ring and go
into a forum well you might be able to
reach some of those crossover swing
voters or people that my independence
that might say you know what I think I
feel more certain going with somebody
like her it could happen the point is
she didn't take that chance and you
would think Brian to your point that
other people made this same mistake that
they would learn how many high paid
consultants and experts does it take to
figure it out when you have eyeballs in
the reach of a network like the Fox News
Channel and FBN why wouldn't you take
that opportunity the one thing that
really drives me crazy is if and this
would be true if a conservative went on
MSNBC and then complained on during the
interview like well I know what network
I'm on she did that a few years ago and
I've never forgotten it to go on when
she was going against President Obama
and one of the things in the break she
said is thank God for Fox because we
were the only one asking President Obama
when he was Senator Obama legitimate
questions and we allowed and it was one
of the most remember what a did Obama
yeah I don't know about that but she did
remember she was his rival for a big
nomination and that bill hates him too
right but I will say that what you got
is a situation where she said you know
this week that when Bill Clinton was
running if there had been a Fox News
that he wouldn't have been able to win
because Fox News was so partisan and I
think I've heard from Obama the same
thing that fox news just pillories him
just attacks him and stops you one
though
twice what the legislative agenda that
the Fox News just makes him into this oh
girl right but at the same time the
reality is if you're not talking to
people this goes back to your business
about the salesmen mmm then you're not
selling really not out there making the
pitch they may feel unfairly attacked
but then show some golf she did make a
comment about President Obama in fact we
played that one here it is true that
when you run to
succeed a two-term president of your own
party you have a historical head wind
blowing against you and I refer to that
in the book because it's not just this
campaign can be set apart from
everything that's ever happened in our
politics it is a challenge do you know
what the problem is with this what
permission to speak Dean I'm sorry
that's go ahead he says it's hard she
says it's hard to run as an agent of
change when you come following someone
like President Obama from your party you
don't have to do you have to say I like
President Obama but this is it this is
what I would have done differently yeah
odor in the economy differently about
the regulation when it comes to Syria I
would have done something different in
fact I have a memo here that says on
this date I recommended we start of
bombing order prevents and also like
McCain had to separate from george w
bush like that always happens so what do
you think will happen next time because
the democrats they still have her out
there wanting to create a litigator they
got a sender somewhere too bad no one
that is thinking about running in 2020
has reached out to her know and also see
the same she also said that she doesn't
think she could be friends with donald
trump anymore i guess she didn't mind
his behavior when he was a democrat or
on the correct side of politics giving
her men like her husband who i think she
could be friends with or Harvey
Fierstein or Feinstein's sorry not fire
16 Weinstein she could be friends with
him and she could be friends too upon a
far lesser extent with Al Franken who by
the way no one has yet to follow up on
go on YouTube in Google Al Franken
Howard Stern 1999 please they're waiting
to be discovered
see the difference I did it with
President Trump they're all over but
they're not doing good this one has a
victim that's no one's well let's go
back let's go back for a second to
Hillary's interview with Hugh Hewitt
yeah because I think there are two
things that were interesting to me one
as she says guess what the child health
care is Insurance Program the Trump is
just letting it yet Trump is just
letting it linger and
I supposed to take that up before
December but he as the president has
some authority here some voice and he
has said nothing in support of a program
that will lead people as she said Pete
kids with diabetes and other illnesses
to suffer I think that's wrong second
thing Trump this this very day retweets
something that says Hillary is a corrupt
blank that's actually you know that's
what he does we've accepted this what
about Paul manna for its house arrest
well I'll say it real quick he's under
house arrest which by the way everybody
should want to be under house arrest an
excuse not to go to somebody's piano
recital it's your dream and also the
real punishment is he's not allowed to
drink during it no I think that's that
because he's getting a limited release
from house arrest to travel on the
condition he doesn't drink that he
doesn't drink Wow smoke can he smoke I
might take him smoking if I had to do
that take it back all right
he shouldn't say what she was smoking it
could be some kind of like herbal
cigarettes close were big back in the
day